devra tous aujourd'hui on va parler du
nouvel iphone 8 plus lu gré avec cette
jolie boîte on n'a pas de sous
[Musique]
c'est là
elle
l'iphone but plus le nouvel iphone de
2007 aura en tout cas un des nouveaux
iphone de 2017 il y à l'iphone 8
l'iphone il y plus et l'iphone 10
l'iphone disent on va par là
prochainement il va le tester ensemble
pour l'instant les pentes en sortie on
va se concentrer sur ce qu'on a à savoir
l'iphone 8 plus bas à tester l'iphone 8
je pense qu'il faut directement les sur
le modèle le plus intéressant à savoir
le 8 plus pourquoi parce que vous avez
la double caméra à l'arrière vous avez
un produit qui est quand même très
complet avec la nouvelle puce à 11km
faire pas mal de choses et notamment la
réalité augmentée et ça c'est juste
extraordinaire alors extraordinaire oui
non pour l'instant la réalité watten
encore accru aux balbutiements donc on
va avoir des applications intéressantes
comme celle d'ikea qui me permet de me
projeter des drogues dans votre
intérieur pour vous rendre compte si
c'est intéressant pour ma part j'ai
testé les dinosaures grandeur nature
c'est marrant il ya peut être les
rigoles d'affaires mais voilà on n'en
est qu'au début donc pour l'instant faut
pas trop s'exciter autour de la réalité
augmentée mais en attendant on avance
énormément il va y avoir plein de choses
dans les temps à venir pour l'instant on
va se concentrer là dessus
le véritable à tout ce téléphone c'est
bien évidemment le grand écran un écran
retina 5,5 pouces en full hd 1920 par
1080 à 400 ppp alors on regrette par
contre que sur l'iphone 8 on n'est pas
du full hd
on n'est qu'en 1334 par 750 à 326 ppp on
a du mal à comprendre que sur un
téléphone coûte aussi cher en 2017 on
soit pour moi sur du full hd bon ça
c'est un peu le détail qui fait un peu
râler
avec un écran lcd pas de oled là dessus
pourquoi parce qu'il est réservé sur la
nouvelle gamme sur les iphone x100 les
fautes 10 mais ça va là on en parlera un
peu plus tard en ce qui concerne cet
appareil il est très réactif il
fonctionne super bien réagi très
rapidement à toutes les ouvertures et à
toutes les sollicitations technique
qu'on peut lui faire c'est vraiment
l'intérêt de ce produit cette nouvelle
puce à 11 fonctionne relativement bien
en a franchement rien à lui reprocher
maintenant ce qui est vraiment sympa là
dessus c'est les modes de photos et de
vidéos
on est effectivement un double capteur à
l'arrière un grand angle et un
téléobjectif
ça va vous permettre d'avoir un zoom
optique x 2 permettra effectivement de
faire un zoom sans perte de qualité et
ça s'est très très bien
[Musique]
votre caméra lorsque filmé en vidéo est
stabilisé ça c'est vraiment intéressant
on va regarder ça en temps parce que
vous avez une vraie différence avec la
caméra vente qui par contre elle n'est
pas du tout stabilisé donc là je teste
la caméra avant de l'iphone 8
voilà donc là on profite des couleurs un
peu de l'automne avec un lac
si vous voulez vous baigner voilà
maintenant la caméra arrière de l'iphone
8 toujours ce fameux lac derrière donc
bon normalement ici on est un petit peu
plus stabilisé alors ça reste toujours
un téléphone à la main si on veut
vraiment et de stabiliser ce qu'il faut
faire savoir un game bol c'est
extrêmement simple il y en a plein qui
existe sur le marché vous avez l'os
mobile est différent game boy comme ça
c'est vraiment bien lorsque vous filmez
avec un téléphone à la main s'est
rapidement le bazar où ma part j'ai
réalisé développe à berlin d'ailleurs si
vous verrez dans la vidéo
le lien est ici en obtenant comme ça à
la main c'est bien mais dès que ça bouge
ça ce vote utile c'est pas terrible bon
vous pouvez filmer uniquement avec la
caméra arrière si vous voyez une qualité
je voulais quelque chose qui soit plus
ou moins stabilisé sur tout ce qui fait
la spécificité technique de style soigné
plus c'est surtout son mode de judo
photo parce que j'arrivais déjà le mode
portrait l'année dernière qui avait
vraiment super bien cartonné sur
l'iphone cette plus aujourd'hui et
l'iphone 8 + va encore plus loin alors
c'est une version bêta pour apporter je
dirais de la qualité photo
professionnelle voilà donc on va tcc
ensemble et on va regarder c'est
intéressant mais normalement c'est
plutôt bien mais par contre ce qui est
important c'est d'avoir une bonne
lumière autre nouveauté intéressante
c'est le mode portrait qu'il a proposé
l'éclairage naturel avec un effet bloqué
qui avoue flouté l'arrière-plan c'est
plutôt bien mais sans le connaissez déjà
sur l'iphone c'est plus vous avez
effectivement sylvain l'éclairage de
studio je vous rajoute un peu plus de
lumière sur notre sur notre visage c'est
vraiment impressionnant
vous avez ensuite l'éclairage des
contours c'est bien intéressant ça
fonctionne plutôt pas mal
l'éclairage de seine et l'éclairage de
seine mono pour faire des photos en noir
et blanc si vous n'êtes pas très bien
éclairé
ça va être tout compliquer votre iphone
aura vraiment du mal à trouver les
contours exacts les contours nets il ya
quelquechose encore à améliorer alors si
on fait un effort de mémoire à l'iphone
cette plus lorsqu'il est sorti du mode
portrait s'était pas encore tout à fait
ça les nouvelles fonctionnalités sont
pas encore idéal
il ya des bugs on n'est que sur une
version bêta donc ne nous excitons pas
trop dans mon bar que ça donnait mais
pour l'instant c'est vraiment très
prometteur
[Musique]
avec ses caméras faire des vrais ralenti
soit en full hd à 120 images par seconde
soit carrément en 240 images par seconde
cela permettra d'avoir des ralentis qui
sont extrêmement fluide et ça c'est top
[Musique]
donc lorsqu'on parle de cannes et
arrière de l'iphone 8 plus ici et de
l'iphone 6 aces ici il ya une vraie
différence au niveau de la lumière au
niveau de pas mal de choses
c'est normal quand même une vraie
différence entre le 8 plus et le 6 s
voilà un petit comparatif pour se rendre
compte autant à tester la caméra de face
et là on compare les caméras de phase là
on est sur les faunes vite plus et l'a
emmené sans l'iphone 6 s et si moi j'ai
le modèle avec le dos en verre blanc qui
est très jolie c'est vraiment un
appareil qui a extrêmement premium et
qui fait vraiment très très qualitatif
très facile de prise en main voyait
alors j'ai pas d énormes mains mais
lorsque vous le tenez comme ça il tient
dans la main il tient dans la poche vous
pouvez glisser dans un sac très
facilement j'ai rien à reprocher au
format que je trouve même plutôt bien et
plutôt compact le dock et anvers ont le
retrouver sur un ancien iphone sur
l'iphone 4 je vous dis pas de bêtises on
avait un dos en verre qui était bien
qu'il y avait la particularité de rayer
un qui serait très très facilement ça
c'était vraiment le problème de ceux
dont le vert mais mes gars côté premium
il ya un côté vraiment bel objet qu'on
retrouve sur cet iphone 8 plus ils sont
l'iphone 8 avec elle des lignes qui sont
incurvés quelque chose qui est très
sympa ça laisse pas énormément de
marques
je craignais que s'en laissent plus mais
saddam j'ai testé par exemple le au nord
9 qui lui laisse beaucoup plus de
marques mais pour l'instant sur cet
iphone là il n'y a pas énormément de
chose à craindre de ce côté là après les
choses contreportes sont les rayures
j'ai peur que ça se marque très
rapidement dans le temps il faut quand
même le protégé alors un dos rambert
pourquoi doit envers tout simplement
pour pouvoir avoir de la recharge par
induction vous puissiez poser votre
téléphone
leurs charges et alors la recharge par
induction un point négatif c'est qui
mettra beaucoup plus de temps que la
recharge classique pour apple c'est une
avancée je dois de fournisseurs ça
existait depuis quand même relativement
longtemps
apple avait déjà dure pas là dessus ils
ont comblé leur retard bon alors il n'y
a pas de grandes avancées technologies
mais bon ça fonctionne alors on va
effectivement aussi qu'ils prennent dans
les litiges aujourd'hui
les chargeur à induction d'autres
marques vous pouvez par exemple si vous
avez un samsung utiliser le chargeur
réduction de 5 de son ca marche très
bien pourquoi simplement parce que la
recharge par induction la retrouver dans
des automobiles dans différents domaines
et pour être compatibles il faut
effectivement que le matériel soit
compatible avec tous ces systèmes l'a
donc pour le coup apple peut pas faire
un site est le propriétaire
et ça c'est plutôt intéressant autre
point qui est bien et pas bien vous avez
le hdr qui installé automatiquement sur
toutes vos images alors le point négatif
est que vous pouvez pas le désactiver
directement dans votre dans votre mode
appareil photo par contre vous avez la
possibilité de le désengorger
directement ici avec l'âge des airs
automatique vous le désactiver pour à ce
moment là soit l'acte iv soit désactivée
directement dans votre mode appareil
photo en surpoids qui est très
intéressant aussi là dessus pour les
audiophiles c'est les haut parleurs
stéréo alors les haut parleurs stéréo on
les trouve déjà sur le modèle antérieur
sur l'iphone cette es7 plus mais sur ce
modèle là il ya un peu plus de puissance
sonore
il faut reconnaître que c'est pas
négligeable c'est intéressant si vous
voulez mettre du son et côté une vidéo
sur youtube au maître de la musique
d'ambiance directement sur votre
téléphone
ça fait le job c'est bien et dont on n'a
rien à lui reprocher l'enceinte est
entre d'un côté l'iphone 8 plus le côté
l'iphone 6 s pour vraiment voir la
différence un faible luminosité pour
l'instant j'ai deux éclairages un de
chaque côté donc normalement n'y a pas
une énorme différence alors forcément on
se reparle eden capteurs on n'est pas
sur la même spécification technique donc
pas forcément une petite différence mais
maintenant je vais couper les lumières
maintenant il me reste juste l'éclairage
le rétroéclairage de mon ordinateur je
suis dans le noir complet
et là on voit la différence entre d'un
côté l'iphone buts +7 côté l'iphone 6 s
l'iphone le téléphone le plus on le trou
tonnes alors le trou tonnes le trottoir
vous permet d'avoir une modulation au
niveau de la balance des blancs pour un
vrai confort de lecture en fonction de
la lumière ambiante
ce qui fait qu'on n'a pas forcément la
même lumière le matin le midi le soir
etc à l'amour quand on est la nuit dans
son lit
le soir au coucher en tout cas à vouloir
regarder son smartphone avant de dormir
d'ailleurs ce que je vous déconseille
parce que c'est pas très très bon
pendant diable c'est une autre histoire
on en parlera peut-être une prochaine
fois ça vous permet effectivement le
trotteur d'avoir une vraie variations au
niveau de la balance des blancs ça vous
protège les yeux ça évite d'avoir
quelque chose de trop agressif et c'est
vrai quand même que c'est intéressant
quand on sent quand même la différence
alors c'est pas flagrant au premier coup
d'oeil mais quand on y prête vraiment
attention
il ya un vrai confort au niveau du
visionnage et ça c'est un vrai point
positif cet iphone vient trouver une
place supplémentaire comme étant l'
iphone qui sera bientôt les iphone
ancienne génération avec ses grands
bords et surtout sur de l'écran lcd mais
il vient vraiment compléter la gamme
apporter un iphone supplémentaire
apporté un peu plus de puissance à
puissance qu'on peut retrouver dans
l'iphone 10 on l'a ici au niveau de la
pub donc rien à envier en termes de
spécifications techniques au niveau de
la puissance par rapport à l'iphone 10
si ce n'est qu'il n'ya pas d'écran oled
si ce n'est qu'il n'y a pas un écran
bord à bord mais si vous voulez un très
bon smartphone qui coûte moins cher
iphone 10 pour filmer faire une bonne
image de belles photos de belles vidéos
l'iphone 8 plus c'est l'iphone 8 font
vraiment le job personnellement je vous
recommande vivement l'iphone lui plus
tout simplement parce qu'avec le double
capteur vous avez le talent objectifs et
le grand-angle c'est vraiment bien que
l'on peut se reproduire aujourd'hui sur
cet iphone 8 plus vous pouvez vous ce
que vous en pensez
est ce que vous l'avez acheté si oui
qu'est-ce que vous en pensez est ce que
vous vous retrouvez un peu dans ce que
je vous ai montré dans cette vidéo
parce que c'est un produit que vous
pourriez acheter ce que vous attendez à
l'iphone 10 votes auraient carrément
l'iphone de 2018 iphone 9 iphone 11 on
connaît pas encore le nom est-ce que
vous pensez que cet iphone sera plus
intéressant quant à moi je vous invite à
vous abonner parce qu'on a toujours plus
de contenu haut
l'ateq pour vous parler des nouveaux
produits des innovations des start up
française qui se développe il ya plein
plein plein de choses admire a donné
vous mettez moi vos commentaires quant à
moi je vous dis à très bientôt et d'ici
là soyez sages
[Musique]